hello and welcome to this video playing
Martha bollocks
can I do let's try something offbeat
have an idea here okay okay just just
play quick moves an Indian bike is okay
of course but to say very healthy set up
for white and interesting yeah I know
taking also certain made some sense but
here he probably has to yeah I'm give up
more time even or invest more time maybe
taking with the Queen is interesting
getting getting the Queen over to the
king side is an interesting idea I'm
trying this the Queen age for Bishop h6
[Music]
maybe a bit unnatural but okay yeah
bishop age six or not di bishop age six
is probably good weakening his King
positional ordered how do i play here
with I wanted to say rookie six but if
that's not happening now
okay let's take this dad problem still
extremely solid for black can't do much
here really trying to play with h4 maybe
later now I'm at least attacking c5 but
maybe just place Queen to e7 no we take
such room that looks like it's more
achievement at least for me
[Music]
yeah it's not a lot maybe it's a slight
edge Queeny five looks correct maybe no
okay let's fix that on the light square
I still cannot do very much feels quite
equal yeah I say I think probably 25
still yeah I don't know I can also take
Queenie for all this ones is the most
conservative move I think it might be
too symmetrical might be too symmetrical
sea angling for Bishop f5 male you
okay
hmm should be too
can you play Bishop g4 here if I take it
f5 King g7 can have to connect six King
G speaking aged five and forty six
before now that that's it's a twins
quite so we have to play this move okay
it's kind of stuck to that corn
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
check to put it on this later here so
that the King cannot enter and I can try
to go to the Queen side it's probably
not nothing much
on a 45
[Music]
[Music]
taking Bishop takes h5 is going to be
better off to know and know
I still can try some things probably
still better here and it's true it's
difficult to do much time warning
King moves I hope we should be fired I
feel slightly critical check my dad
wrong but I don't think it is
I kept the King b7 alright stupid but
okay black realize yeah yeah bring
probably it's a troll but you can why
this always a bit better here with the
better be sure friend to it can you can
try things five okay it's probably at
wrong and now can you for is winning
yeah yeah I'd say it's it's not so easy
and he has to be quite precise King c7
we will draw at 10 Jesus yeah also now
cannot do much yeah that's just a
straight loss and here I mean he can
move the bishop but just taking a five
and doing this easily okay let's let's
have a ever loop down there one yeah not
that many things happening maybe this
idea wasn't all that successful this is
maybe too simple it's always comfortable
this pollution but you're not doing all
that much
we're for a fee and we like the ending
simple to play but maybe it's just it
wrong
okay guys thanks for watching